I was evicted when I was 14 we were
kicked off the island we couldn't live
in Hawaii had no place to live when I
moved to New York City I had nothing
else a dirt-poor kid no education
rise and shine it's an spresso time
what's up belief nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message remember the hard
times over to you Dwayne the rock
Johnson also if you want to know what
Dwayne and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
the description below my call time is at
7 then you back your clock up for hours
and then that's when I get up so before
a big movie comes out before back in the
days when I was wrestling with WWE a
Wrestlemania match anything big that
would happen I would always take a
moment and I just remind myself all
right I was evicted when I was 14 we
were kicked off the island we couldn't
live in Hawaii and no place to live what
happened then when I moved to Nashville
I was arrested multiple times by the
time I was 16 years old I got remember
that if I were playing on this team
which might you know my skills are
what's that term oh so I never play but
before I lace up before I get on the
court before I playing these big games
before I go to the Staples Center where
history says those are those are
historic we'll all sit here at the
Staples Center I would remember that and
it allows me then to be present in the
moment and understand holy that's the
stuff I have around me right now this is
it that I dreamed of when I was a kid I
am here what helps me is to keep the
hard times in the front of my mind
because it allows me to go into these
big moments that I've worked my ass off
and you guys have worked your ass off it
allows me to go into these big moments
with a different perspective now I've
got a really special bonus clip for you
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for a question of
the day I want to know what hard times
have you gone through that keep you
pushing forward leave your answers in
the comments below
remember when I moved to New York City
19 years old 20 years old I had nothing
outside a dirt-poor kid with no
education and I met all these rich kids
and I idolized them I was like Todd they
have trust funds they have money they
have all these resources all these
worries that I have they don't get to
sleep over southern harmony tomorrow
they don't have that so jealous of these
people in any of them I didn't watch
grow up and we grew up together and
parson brought in to really struggle to
find a purpose in life because they
didn't have to they didn't need to find
a purpose they didn't we go out there
and fight to find a job out there just
like because so I kept my job at
McKinley and part-time I started in the
financial services industry and started
to build a team of people and started to
get my licenses and that transition and
I struggled like every upstart
entrepreneur does I think it's like
three to five years until you really get
a few clients you know in any business I
don't care if it's financial services
tech a dry cleaners entrepreneurs the
first five years is just full of false
starts and get it going then you don't
you get it going you take a step forward
you take three back its constant false
starts it's constantly thinking you have
it going it's constantly negotiating in
your mind the price you're paying is it
worth that should I quit
should I give in I'm constantly I spent
the first five years daily contemplating
quitting yeah all the time because it's
not fun it wasn't fun and and there's
just a part of you thinking anything
you're doing when you're struggling is
this really for me is this my destiny
should I be doing this and we miss Reed
failure from some sign you know is this
a sign I shouldn't be doing it
was this a sign I am you know not cut
out for this instead of looking for
signs that you can win right and so I
spent the first five years literally
trying to find ways to quit trying to
find ways to get out struggling and
struggling and struggling and I went
broke I lost a car and the water turned
off in my place I you know I bought out
my first house I ended up having it
foreclosed on eventually so I'm not that
house with the unicorns that you saw
right or my beach place like that's all
they after people don't realize that
there were just years and years of of
grinding and struggling and worrying in
the beginning and then then I made some
mental changes and some ships yeah that
altered my life then again so raise your
standard value not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's
something severe if you want more of the
rock check of the motivational video I
did on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there it's
4:45 a.m. it's still dark outside look
at that the lights just went out and I'm
getting ready to kill this am car do you
can't even see me but it's gonna be so
good it's bad